lo que tengo aquí es una representación
visual de una función
esta es una representación de que es
igual a hdx existen muchas personas que
cuando ven a una función descrita con
esta anotación lo ven como algo
intimidante hasta que entienden de qué
se trata todas las funciones toman algo
como una entrada en este caso toman x
con una entrada realizan algo con esto y
devuelven otro valor que se da igual ahí
así que por ejemplo que obtenemos en hd
4 con base en esta gráfica que tenemos
aquí pausa el vídeo y piénsalo por tu
cuenta
todo lo que nos dice hd4 es que el poner
como entrada a 4 en nuestra función que
llevo y obtener o dicho de otra manera
cuando x es igual a 4 que es igual que
bueno cuando x es igual a 4 en nuestra
función obtenemos que y es igual a 3 lo
sabemos por este punto de aquí y es
igual a 3
entonces hd 4 es igual a 3 bien hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí es igual h de 0 pausa
el vídeo e inténtalo
bueno todo lo que dice es que si pongo a
x igual a 0 como entrada de nuestra
función cuál será la que correspondiente
que obtenemos bueno podemos ver que
cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual a 4 así
de simple
dada la entrada cuál será la salida y
eso es lo que representan estos puntos
todos estos puntos representan una
salida distinta para una entrada dada
ahora siempre es bueno tener en cuenta
una de las cosas que hacen que una
función sea una función y es que para
una x dada como entrada obtengas solo un
ayer por ejemplo si tuviéramos dos
puntos por aquí entonces tendríamos dos
puntos para x igual a 6 de repente
tenemos un problema para conocer el
valor que se obtiene en hd 6 ya que
puede ser uno o tres por lo tanto si
tenemos este punto extra entonces esta
no será más una función para que sea una
función tiene que pasar que para cada x
obtienes un único valor de salida no
puedes obtener dos posibles valores
ahora bien si es posible de la otra
manera es posible que tengas dos valores
diferentes para x para un cierto valor
de salida por ejemplo si aquí tuviéramos
otro punto cuál sería el valor que se
obtiene en hd menos 4 bueno hd menos 4
cuando ponemos a x es igual a menos 4 en
nuestra función parece que obtenemos
como salida a 2
entonces h de menos 4 es igual a 20 h de
2 es también igual a 2
lo podemos ver de manera clara justo
aquí cuando ponemos 2 como entradas
nuestra función el valor correspondiente
que es también 2 si los dos valores de x
se mapean en el mismo valor de que está
bien eso funciona pero si tienes algún
tipo de relación donde para una cierta x
dada
obtengas dos valores diferentes de y
entonces eso no sería una función pero
en este caso tenemos la función
asumiendo que no la modifique en ningún
momento